oh hi you know last year around this
time you took a look at Final Fantasy
crystal chronicles ring of fates for the
nintendo ds's an action-packed
multiplayer centric take on everybody's
favorite role playing game series that
despite a few flaws was actually a lot
of fun and now we've got Final Fantasy
crystal chronicles echoes of time in
large part it's almost the same game
same engine same gameplay style at a
kind of feels like an expansion pack
which considering the last game was only
about 10 hours isn't a bad thing but
there's a twist this time echoes of time
is available for both the DS and the
week and owners of both consoles can
play the game together the wii version
of echoes of time basically just looks
like a DS game running on your
television set you can adjust the
relative sizes of the two screens and
use the pointer to click on anything
that's on the ds's touchscreen so why
bother taking a DS game and shoving it
onto the wii well because the wii
version tricks other nintendo ds's into
thinking that it too is a nintendo DS
game which means that you can play on
the DS and on the wii in the exact same
game the wii version and the DS version
can go online if you don't have anybody
in the same room with you unfortunately
echoes of time is not quite as engaging
for single players while ring of fates
had a detailed story a lot of very funny
characters echo sometimes single player
mode feels a lot thinner it's very
obviously designed for multiplayer
gaming the writing is still occasionally
laugh-out-loud funny and the core
gameplay is solid but in the one player
mode there's a lot less to see and do we
give Final Fantasy crystal chronicles
echoes of time a 7 out of 10 by now
you've probably already heard a lot
about the final fantasy 13 demo which
came out in japan in april of for the
playstation 3 we've actually been
playing the demo a few times and uh it's
you know kind of freaks us out a little
bit we were gonna come up with a list of
13 things that freak us out but it's a
really short demo so we just got for
number one why is the main character's
name lightning but she can only cast
fire spells
I don't get it I think it's one of those
sort of like why do we drive on the
Parkway park on the driveway things just
never going to be explained numbers too
why is there a chocobo living in this
guy's afro seriously who thought that
that was a good idea special thanks to
the game life reader who suggested that
we call it a froak about number three
why is this man giving this little girl
a gun ok I understand these people are
in a desperate fight for survival but
look there's plenty of unarmed adults
all around you give the adult book oh
now she's playing with it oh man oh
these people are toast and number four
why is the demo spoiling the death of
this totally unnamed character oh wait
it's not because when you fall from a
height of a million feet in final
fantasy nothing bad happens to you don't
worry she'll show up again in disc two
maybe she'll have lost her memory but
she'll be no worse for the wear final
fantasy 13 will be released in the
united states in who the hell knows
probably sometime in 2010 so we'll find
out the answers to all of these
mysteries and more in about a year
you